vsauce kevin here and there's a secret
message hidden
in these 144 characters that's a 12 by
12
square grid and every card has its own
coordinates a dozen dozen
a gross i'm gonna decode the message
randomly using dice to choose which
cards i'll turn over and i guarantee it
will work
perfectly in only 11 choices no matter
what
they are then i will show you how to do
this with any message of any life
even an entirely randomly rolled
book here's the setup the grid has
x and y axes numbered 1 through
12. so the very bottom left card is at
1 1 and the top right card
is at 12 12. i have two
12 sided dice one rolls x and one rolls
for y there's an equal probability of
rolling everything from
a one to eight twelve we can't just use
two
normal six sided dice to add up to
twelve because
it would have a probability bell curve
peaking around seven
and it's literally impossible to roll a
one
with two d6 dice all right
here we go roll number one our game
begins okay i got
3 11. all right so i'm going to mark
that card with a big
x and then i'll remove all the cards
above it
below it to the left
and to the right we're wiping out
everything that shares
an x or a y value with each
roll got it let's continue roll number
two seven
six all right seven six right here
same thing mark it with an x wipe out
the column and the row
i'm going to keep playing and if i roll
a number that corresponds to a missing
coordinate like
uh five six which is now
blank i'll just re-roll until i do get
a hit listen at this point there's
something
you need to know desperately i'm
only rolling dice so that you know i'm
choosing cards
randomly but when you play this with
someone you don't
need dice just ask the other person to
choose whatever cards
they want they'll keep choosing until
there's only one card left
without an x and you'll reveal the
perfectly decoded
message and they'll freak out since
they're the ones choosing
they can be sure it's not rigged
more on that later for now let's 80s
action movie montage the rest of my
[Music]
roles
thought we had it all
two hearts that beat as well
[Music]
[Music]
the love we shared is gone
i got a message and i can't believe it's
true
i can't believe that you told me
all right there's only one blank card
left so
that gets our final x all of our
selected coordinates are listed here
on the left i'm gonna put all of the
cards in a row so that
you can read them easily when i flip
them over
wait how is this even possible
i put letters on 144 cards
i randomly choose 12 of them and i'm
left with
exactly the 12 cards i want in exactly
the correct
order there's no way this
is gonna work right
yeah exclamation point waranga
because this is a variation on the magic
square discovered by chinese
mathematicians 2 200 years ago
and tweaked a lot later by canadian
postman and magician
stuart james in a magic square adding up
each row
column and diagonal gives you the same
total
called the magic constant the number of
rows and columns is called the order so
this is a simple
order 3 magic square with a magic
constant of
15. that's not too hard for us now it's
a little like
sudoku but it took another 800 years for
varahamahira to decipher the first
16 block order 4 magic square
in india and 1 000 years after that
we knew there are 880 distinctly
different
magic squares of order four now we have
pan diagonal magic squares multi-magic
squares
methods for creating magic squares of
odd orders and
even orders and they're so complex that
even euler's hypotheses on constructing
evenly odd odd-ordered mutually
orthogonal greco-latin squares
turned out to be wrong but
the one magic square that has fascinated
for centuries
even outside the math community is stuck
in the background of an early 16th
century
german engraving albrecht dura's
melancholia 1
depicts a winged woman who represents
either melancholy and depression
or geometry depending on who you ask
she's surrounded by all sorts of hand
tools an
hourglass a compass a dog
a dog is a dog is not a hand tool dog is
your best friend
and way in the back corner is a very
unique magic square
durer's magic square isn't technically
durs it appears in luca pacioli's de
virbus cuantitatus about 15
years before the engraving pachioli was
leonardo da vinci's teacher and
best friend and the odds that duro
coincidentally came up with the same one
on his own are astronomical the magic
constant endures order for magic square
is 34 but the magic comes by more than
just adding
rows columns and diagonals you could do
each of the four quadrants to get 34.
the four blocks in the center 34 the
outside four corners
34 inner rectangles 34.
diagonal rhombuses 34
the internal 3x3 blocks 34
vertical x 34 and 34 horizontal x 34
and 34 trapezoids 34.
squares that don't use the corners 34.
when you sort and stack just the right
combination of numbers
really incredible patterns happen
and it's the same with words the
classical example is the seder or rhodus
square
found in pompei and through europe the
palindrome
tenet in the middle of the seder square
that's where christopher nolan's movie
title
came from tenet puzzle makers have
successfully made magic word squares up
to order nine
but a true order ten word square is
still considered the holy grail of
recreational
linguistics i did a modified magic
square with 12
and i said you could do it even with a
book of
any length look here's the
mind-blowingly
simple secret you just need to repeat
your hidden message
on as many rows as there are characters
in the word passage or message
check it out hello is just h-e-l-l-o
five times stacked you can do happy
birthday for someone and just be
14 rows including the space you could
randomly recreate the entire harry
potter series you just need
about a five million three hundred
twenty seven thousand by five million
three hundred twenty seven thousand grid
of the book start to finish with a full
book on each row
assuming the series 1 million 84
170 words conform to an average word
length of 4.7 characters and there's a
space
in between each one and how many choices
would it take
if however many rows or columns is equal
to n then it'll take
n minus one choices every
single time no matter how big your
mystery grid is
every time you make a selection and
remove all the other cards on that
selections x
and y planes you eliminate possible
duplicates and
isolate that choice as being the only
letter
that can occupy that specific position
in the column or row it's
weirdly simple it's weirdly complex
it's elegant and amazing in a strange
combination of
mathematical beauty and linguistics
and you can grab a marker and some slips
of paper and play
this secret message game to reveal
something
monumental like proposing to spend
the rest of your life with your
significant other
or get someone to unwittingly spell the
word
but and as always thanks for watching
hey the curiosity box by vsauce is
celebrating its
five year anniversary that's five years
of delivering brain food right to your
door and it's time for you to join us so
to give yourself or someone else the
gift of smart
go to curiositybox.com join our brains
join our